there are all these crazy activists
online with anime avatars and everyone's
a fascist a homophobic nazis whatever
they see it everywhere and they probably
believe it but then you have the
politicians the civil servants the
journos the people who when you ask them
what is a woman they go ah um well it's
complicated and uh and you see the fear
in their eyes they know that all of this
is [ __ ] but they're gonna go along
with it because they think they will
preserve themselves by doing so
andrew doyle welcome to the show thanks
for having me
as a man who has dedicated his life to
thinking about fashion and style i'm
sure that you're familiar with the
recent new york times article redefining
what hotness means saying that hotness
is no longer in the eye of the beholder
it's a mood it's a vibe a social media
movement inspired by the rapper megan
the stallion strikes back at the
gatekeepers of beauty do you see this
i am not familiar with this at all but
maybe it's because i don't go out my way
to find fashion articles wow that
surprises me so many people many people
are expanding the definition of hotness
taking it beyond its former association
with old notions of attractiveness these
days being hot no longer pertains to
only your physical appearance but
includes how you move through the world
and how you see yourself many of those
pushing for a broader understanding of
the term are also pushing back against
the idea that you need to wait for
confirmation from someone else before
feeling justified in calling yourself
hot to them hotness is a
self-declaration and that's that hotness
is no longer in the eye of the beholder
it's a mood it's a vibe emily sundberg
28 year old editor and filmmaker in
brooklyn was eating spaghetti when she
had a realization she was hot there was
nothing glamorous about it it was just a
solo weeknight dinner in the kitchen
counter and ms sundberg was wearing
workout clothes and glasses but she felt
moved to make a video of herself as she
twirled past her strands on a fork and
succeeded succeeded in getting most of
them all the way into her mouth as she
chewed with kanye west's jail blaring in
the background she stared into the lens
with a blank expression so this is
hotness in zoomer generation
what's the sexuality the sexual
orientation where you're attracted to
people because of what the way they
think
their brain is oh
it's something like
scopiosexual or yeah yes sapiosexual say
piosexual there we go sapiosexual
oh my god um yeah i d i wasn't familiar
with this article but you know
it's i guess it's fitting into this this
whole movement's obsession with the way
that beauty
is uh is not a thing beauty is a sort of
a
patriarchal western construct and um
therefore anything can be beautiful but
the thing is some things just aren't
i've seen the video of her twirling her
noodles or pasta or whatever it is into
her mouth
i've seen it done better it's first off
it's not the thing that i think of in
the top echelons of hotness and i've
seen it done better but
you don't have to ask for permission to
be hot online ms sunberg said there's
not one thing that defines what hot is
it's confidence it's the way you dress
it's the way you present yourself to
other people you don't get to decide
whether you're hot well for one thing it
is subjective let's be honest people are
attracted to different types you know
some people are attracted to
you know skinny people some people
attracted to fat people something you
know that you know blondes brunettes
whatever
that's true
um but you don't get to decide that
you're attractive as a kind of label
right i got
can i not self-identify as hot
i wouldn't have thought so because
to whom
you know doesn't it depend
what if someone's you know someone who's
uh like you won't be hot
to a lesbian will you
well maybe that's their prejudice
showing
well if you were the head of stonewall
that's exactly what you would think
ah yeah you had to run in with them
you're not am i well i mean just
generally you're always unhappy with
them no it's not i'm not well no i am
unhappy with them because i think you
know it's such a shame that an important
gay rights group in the uk is now uh
promoting anti-gay ideas so yeah that
makes me a bit sad um nancy kelly the
ceo of stonewall describe women women
lesbians who want who don't want to have
sex with people with penises who
identify as women but are male she
described them as sexual racists i think
that's a problem she compared them to
anti-semites
uh
i think we used to call that kind of
phrase uh homophobic didn't we
so yeah i do and my issue with stonewall
you know quite apart from all the other
things is that i invite them onto my
show constantly all the time
and they just never say yes because they
say we don't have debate
but i want to ask them about their
policies i want to ask them why they
changed the definition of homosexual on
their website and their promotional
materials to same gender attracted which
is not what it means i mean same sex
attracted because gay men aren't
attracted to people who identify as men
they're attracted to men it's very much
about the penis with gay men in my
sort of tangential understanding of what
gay men like it's very much about us
don't pretend that's tangential you've
done some research
clearly you've done it's about the penis
and not just the
penis plasti it's about the
yeah i mean well that's clearly an
element and
the i th you know i get that that
there's more to
uh same sex attraction than genitals
that's absolutely true
but but you're
you can't feign
sexual attraction and you can't relearn
your innate
sexual orientation which is what they're
kind of implying what nancy kelly is
saying in stonewall is what the
homophobes used to say to gay men you
know you just haven't found the right
girl yet you know you need to open your
mind a little bit more you need to you
know all of that stuff it's just
recycled ancient tropes it's really it's
so sad are they saying you haven't found
the right trans man yet
uh well they're suggesting that if you
if you close off
certain demographics from your dating
pool then that's the result of bigotry
but of course everyone does that
everyone does that in one way or another
because everyone has
a type uh someone that they are types of
people that they're attracted to and
sure sometimes there can be people from
other categories that surprise you or
what whatever sexuality is complicated
but the idea that if you're not
attracted to a certain type of person
you need to relearn that and examine
your own bigotry and prejudice it's just
it's just homophobia dressed up as
something else that's all it's also
happening elsewhere right so if you can
see how this hotness discussion would
slowly encroach onto
some sort of bigotry men that don't date
bigger women would be sizes
interestingly you don't see as much
about women dating short men there's not
really as much criticism for women for
doing no if you've got some five foot
five guy and he's saying well why is it
that women shouldn't date me if i have
to date fat girls
doesn't seem
this idea that you you have a right to
be to be attractive to be considered
attractive and you have a right to go
out with someone like someone says no
isn't that the end of the conversation
no i don't know maybe not anymore so
this sunderberg lady finished up here
and she said that doesn't need that
doesn't mean that you have to be the
most symmetrically physically perfect
human being i feel like that isn't even
as desirable anymore our definition of
attraction and attractiveness has
expanded so much well you're publicly
stated preferences have but your
revealed preferences something would
tell me is going to end up with you not
sleeping with the homeless guy on the
street that doesn't have a job and only
has like two teeth
yeah quite exactly this person's a
hypocrite right i i missed this article
i don't know how i missed it did this go
viral i normally get sent this nonsense
because when i i normally because my job
now every day you know i get up in the
morning and i i uh i search for this
stuff or people send me this stuff
because i obviously have to collect
material for my show on the sunday
um so i don't normally miss snook
underneath the radar well i've got i i
went to uh the heterodox academy
conference uh jonathan heights thing out
in denver
and um i was sat around the table with a
bunch of different people and we're all
sharing our favorite resources for where
we go for interesting news articles and
i'll send them over to you once we're
done but there's one called clown worlds
today that has a telegram chat they have
a telegram chat where they send out one
news story each day and that is just if
you're short on things to talk about
that will be a god oh that's great no
send me that that's brilliant although
to be honest i'm not short of stuff
yeah you said um before you started the
show you were worried that you were
gonna run out of stuff to talk about if
you had to do a regular segment on
culture wars and you're killing babies
on a daily daily basis
hilarious because when i started at gb
news i was appearing every night on the
andrew neal show in a segment called
woke watch and uh well most nights
and there was concern yeah you're not
going to be able to appear every night
because there won't be a story every day
there's always a few stories every day
and then certainly for my sunday show
which i go through everything that's
happened in the week i mean i always
have to leave a lot out um yeah well
it's mad i mean and it's got it's
escalated a lot worse since i saw you
last sadly yeah well i mean speaking of
that uh ben shapiro's presence is a
terror organizers of a podcast
conference in dallas texas drew backlash
thursday after they took responsibility
for harm caused by the daily wire
podcast host ben shapiro's presence at
the conference podcast movement a major
annual conference for the podcast
industry issued a profuse apology on
thursday after attendees complained that
shapiro was spotted at the event near
the daily wire booth
remember that ben shapiro is one of the
two founders of the daily wire daily
wire sponsored this year's conference
and shapiro host of the massive
massively successful the benchmare show
podcast was seen pictured walking around
the expo arena did you see the first
tweet that someone responded as a trans
person as a queer person as someone with
a uterus this does not make me feel
welcome this does not make me feel safe
one of the conference attendees posted
on twitter after sharing a picture of
shapiro standing by the daily wire booth
does ben shapiro make you feel you know
you know ben like quick speaking little
hat him does he make you feel
unsafe
um i we have to get beyond this unsafe
nonsense we have to stop taking it
seriously when anyone says it it's the
go-to thing isn't it ben shapiro is not
a threat to anyone he's just maybe has a
different opinion than you like just
this is it's so childish
but it's happening all the time this
phrase unsafe it's been used against me
of course i've had the same thing i lost
a job because someone claimed that my
presence made them unsafe because of a
joke i'd told uh this sort of thing
happens all the time um when jerry
sadowitz the the scottish comedian he
had his show pulled at the end of the
fringe uh last week
and the venue said that his material was
making people feel unsafe so even now
comedy promoters are claiming that words
are violence uh it's i mean something
you and i have discussed before it's
something that we've been warning about
for a long time but look
we just need to start laughing in
people's faces when they say this stuff
it's absolutely ridiculous words are not
hurting you if you're offended then then
that's fair enough everyone gets
offended from time to time that's being
human but you're not physically harmed
the groveling apology from podcast
movement said hi folks we owe you an
apology before sessions kick off for the
day yesterday afternoon ben shapiro
briefly visited the pm 22 expo area near
the daily wire booth though he was not
registered or expected we take full
responsibility for the harm done by his
presence there's no way around it we
agreed to sell the daily wire at a first
time booth based on the company's large
presence in podcasting let's not forget
that they've got probably
two or three of the top 10 podcasts in
the world at any one time matt walsh
will be up there uh ben shapiro will be
up there the morning wire is
unbelievably huge it's this 15 minute
thing there's now making movies and blah
blah blah the weight of that decision is
now painfully clear shapiro is a
co-founder a drop in however unlikely
should have been considered a
possibility those of you who called this
unacceptable are right in nine wonderful
years growing and celebrating this
medium pm has made mistakes the pain
caused by this one will always stick
with us we promise that sponsors will be
more carefully considered moving forward
the pain it was a brief visit right he
said benchmark briefly visited
if that's all it takes to to to
you know reduce you to connections then
you really need to see a doctor about
that because
it's i mean i don't know what to do
about this sort of stuff i you know i've
been raining against it well you know
i've written a book now about it i'm i'm
i i think we need to stop tolerating it
i think we need to laugh it out of
existence i think i i think that there
is a very real place for ridicule to be
used here as one of the most important
uh pushback mechanisms because
the game that's being played a lot of
the time is this sort of faux
intellectual lexical overload semantic
game
brazilian jiu jitsu [ __ ] that's going
on and
trying to engage with it on a serious
level
kind of legitimate the position that the
other side has whereas if you see what
happened with
uh pc and then with the word woke how
quickly it became
you can't use the word woke
unironically anymore it's not a serious
term and the reason that that happened
is because people like yourself and
other comedians and online commentators
very quickly made it a caricature of
itself and yeah you can try and mandate
something or um how do you say
logically
reduce it down so that people don't want
to be associated with it but if you just
make it so uncool and socially toxic to
be associated with that no one wants to
use it anymore that's it dead in the
water yeah well i've tried that i mean
i've done a lot of the comedy stuff and
the satire stuff and i've written two
satirical books mocking this thing
my new book
is not that my new book is
trying to get to grips with it however
what i would say in my defense there
is i get what you're saying about you
know you can't really reason but the the
new book i've written isn't aimed at the
woke it is about the woke and it's
therefore an attempt
to uh because
most of the people who support who think
that they support the woke movement or
whatever we want to call them the
critical social justice movement
whatever
they don't really fully grasp what
they're about and so this is a book
where we talk through what where i try
and explain what it is that their
objectives are how really the culture
war is a
a battle over language and who gets to
define language i mean you've raised it
yourself there political correctness
woke i've got a whole section of the
book about the evolution of the word
woke and how it was a form of self
identification for activists at one
point and then because people like me
started mock using the word to describe
them sometimes in a mocking way
they then started to pretend that it was
a right-wing term that people like me
had invented as an insult
which isn't true because you know we can
check that on google just go back people
used to it self-identifies work all the
time there are i've got screenshots of
loads of guardian articles talking
unironically about being woke
so that's not true
so um but but that's what they do is
that because this is a culture war about
language
uh these people who i call the new
puritans in my book
continually redefine language and then
they will tell you that they haven't
done so
so you're using words that you always
used to use but now they're telling you
they mean something different so you
used to think the word racism meant
prejudice or hate against someone due to
the color of their skin and now you're
told no it doesn't mean that it means an
equation prejudice plus power and it's
to do with power structures in society
and therefore white people uh non-white
people can't be racist and etc etc um
and you're told no the definitions
change now even though no one really
uses it in this way you we're telling
you it's it's done this way now so um
yeah so i think there are two prongs in
in in the pushback and i think one is
humor and one is satire and and we can
keep doing that but i think you need the
other prong as well because i think you
need to persuade the unpersuaded and
there's a whole army of decent
liberal-minded people who are probably
quite humorous a lot of them they're not
going to respond to the satirical
approach they might even think it's mean
and particularly because they don't they
they have
fallen for the lexicon they've fallen
for the linguistic trick right they hear
phrases like social justice anti-racism
equity and they're like this sounds
great i'm opposed to racism i'm for
justice and equality that's brilliant so
i will support this and if you don't
support this then surely you're a nasty
reactionary and they've fallen for that
basic trick and that's part of the point
of course so what i'm trying to do in
the book is sort of talk through what
these phrases actually mean what the
implications actually are and how this
movement is
against liberalism if i you know i say
that i make the point that i think the
closest synonym to the word woke is
anti-liberal and i think that's what
this is an explicitly anti-liberal
movement if you read the early critical
race theorists like richard delgado he
explicitly says we are against
liberalism liberalism fails us because
because prejudice is built into the
liberal system so
you know it's um
yeah it's about it's about language
that's my that's my take home
is this a new phenomenon because to me
it seems like the semantic [ __ ] that
we've got that's going on is happening
at a quicker pace maybe it's simply that
we have a record of it that's
kind of uh
kept
online for everybody to see at all times
and uh the wayback machine and
archive.org and stuff helps you to be
able to compare what was and what
wouldn't be whereas i guess 1984 in a
world where you can actually get rid of
the history of things is a little bit
different is is this a new phenomenon
have words been being reinvented to be
used to manipulate impressions for a
long time
how does all that work um well i mean
it's all there have always been people
and particularly tyrannies have always
um redefined words or limited the the
words that can be used um in any given
situation or they've you know i mean you
just have to read 1984 to understand how
how that's working but
people have always done this i mean
phrases such as um
when the cai cia started calling torture
enhanced interrogation for instance uh
that would be an example they've
been all in um in the archipelago
there's an example of this uh where
solzhenitsyn talks about and i can't
remember what he says i can check it
actually he says um
he's talking about people who are
sentenced
sentence and they don't use the phrase
sentencing they use something else
i can't remember what it is i'll have to
find it for you at some point um but
they you know tyrants have always done
this they've always played word games to
try and
create a false reality that you have to
subscribe to i think though there's
something going on at the moment where
what the social justice activists do
is maddening because they don't just
modify meanings and modify definitions
often the things that they say are the
direct opposite of what they mean
and that is
and it leaves you
unmoored and confused what's an example
of that
sorry what's an example of that where
they say something that's the opposite
of what they mean
okay so they have uh convinced most
people that
trans conversion therapy is the
equivalent to gay conversion therapy and
so you had a lot of labour mp standing
there with placard saying we want to ban
on trans conversion therapy what trans
conversion therapy means is a young
person who has feelings of gender
dysphoria goes to an expert a specialist
and the specialist talks to them about
it but it doesn't just affirm the gender
they think they are
it doesn't just fast track them onto
puberty blockers but says to them let's
investigate this a bit through
therapeutic means let's discuss maybe
it's to do with maybe you're gay and
you're you're you're struggling with
that maybe it's autism because there's a
hypopungence of autistic people that
fall into that category etc
and trans activists have called that
trans conversion therapy so now labor
but what that means of course is you are
affirming gender dysphoria among
predominantly gay kids and fast-tracking
them on puberty blockers that will
essentially heterosexualize and fix
those gay kids so you actually have and
that is a form of conversion therapy so
when a labour mp holds a placard saying
ban conversion therapy the placard
actually means i support conversion
therapy
it's tough isn't it
yeah well it is for you so you in the
new book you say that we're living
through a frenzy of conformity what does
that mean
what i mean by that is that uh we are
expected to go along with the rubric uh
that everyone is um
effectively
the overton window is shrinking to such
a degree and if you dare to stray
outside of it if you dare to challenge
some of the the norms of the the the
ideas of the social justice movement
uh they'll come after you they'll
continue a pariah even a slightest point
of disagreement and they will they will
devastate your life and they won't
hesitate to bully you trust your
reputation target your employer
what we call council culture in other
words and so people are
uh conforming people are
taking the the path of least resistance
now
in the in my book i talk about salem a
lot and i draw comparisons between what
happened with the witch trials of salem
at the end of the 17th century and what
we're living through now because what
interests me about that is salem this
was not a typical thing that would
happen among the puritan community in
new england this was they were not witch
hunters this wasn't who they were they
weren't like the witch hunters of europe
who killed burned thousands of people uh
this was an aberration this was this was
odd and it only lasted a year it started
very quickly and then it died off very
quickly and afterwards everyone said we
got that wrong everyone repented you
know they knew it was wrong they just
got caught up in this hysteria
but the reason why
it happened is because the elites the
magistrates and the ministers
went along with it
uh and i think the more i've read about
it i've read a number of books about it
and the more i've read about it i've
realized that that is large that was
largely due to self-preservation for
reasons of
self-preservation give us
i want the full understanding of the
salem witch trials and why it came about
because i've heard it it gets bandied
about as a
thing that
happens in popular culture but i don't
understand what went on
well okay i will tell you what went on
and and i talk about it extensively in
my book because i think it
i think as an analogy it helps us it
helps to explain a lot of what we're
living through now but also i think it
holds the key for how we're going to
escape it and that's why i wanted to
draw this connection so this was uh 1692
there's a a small community salem
village
um and
there are uh it's a puritan community
it's a very god-fearing community very
devout
uh the reverend samuel paris
uh has a uh daughter betty paris and
also has a niece abigail williams and
they they are young girls and they live
with him
along with two slaves that he has uh one
of the slaves is called tituba and she
spent some time in barbados and she has
all these sort of voodoo style spells
and things which are perfectly harmless
clearly she plays these games with the
kids and she teaches them these spells
and it's it's it's not it's not meant to
be taken too seriously then betty paris
starts uh acting in a funny way uh is
bedridden and has visions and thinks she
can fly and all sorts of things like
this and and um
and a local physician thinks she's been
possessed by the devil then abigail
williams has a similar reaction and says
that she has seen witches in the
community and before long other girls
friends of theirs people who have
associated with them start saying
i you know this woman's a witch that
woman's a witch started starting
accusing people often the targets are
quite obvious people uh people like
bridget bishop who was the first to be
hanged
you know she was known for being wearing
ostentatious showy clothes which was
unusual in a puritan community she ran
two taverns where people would get drunk
and ever not to get drunk have fun end
up cruising late night cruising you know
and um
and and so she's an obvious target to
accuse uh also there were rumors that
she'd taken a lover out of wedlock and
suddenly all these people start getting
accused but it mounts and it grows and
then when people start being skeptical
and saying look maybe this isn't real
maybe the girls are just hysterical
maybe the girls are just going through a
silly season you know
those people get accused as well and it
soon becomes clear
that anyone who
casts doubt onto the girls testimonies
will themselves
be accused and and hauled into court and
some of the most devout people in the
community rebecca nurse was one of the
most devout christian women of that
community an upstanding
hugely respected member of the community
and she was accused of being a witch as
well she goes to court
in the courtroom
these girls
point at the the accused scream that
that that woman is sending her spirit
out to pinch them choke them attack them
sometimes they see the spirit fly up
onto the beam as a as a a yellow bird or
they can si or you know so they see all
this and they describe it and they're
screaming and writhing
they mimic the actions of the accused so
when bridget bishop is standing at the
at the uh on the stand and she rolls her
eyes because of what the girls are doing
all of the girls then simultaneously
roll their eyes
and it gives the impression that they're
possessed and and this is taken as proof
that these women are in fact witches in
in consult with the devil
they called it spectral evidence
and in my book i compare that to lived
experience
because the girls say this is our truth
this is our perception and we don't need
any other evidence in that
and then they start being sentenced to
death and hanged
anyone who was accused to confess to
witchcraft wasn't hanged because the
puritans believed in mercy and they were
very lenient if you confessed so the
ones that hanged and in the end 20 were
executed they would have been the most
devout
of of of the puritans the most the most
god-fearing because they're not going to
damn their soul by lying in a court of
law
so
there's a few reasons i wanted to make
the connection with salem firstly
there's the
the sheer hysteria of what happened
there uh
this idea of of the human susceptibility
for group think going along with false
narratives because it explains something
that's quite difficult to understand
but most importantly it's the fear that
it inspired it's the fact that
um people conformed i think the hysteria
may have been real among the girls
there's all sorts of theories about why
they were experiencing
these panics
maybe they thought they were seeing
witches we don't know
um but what is for sure is that some of
the judges didn't
because
whenever they accused a local dignitary
someone who meant something so they
accused the governor
they accused the uh colony colonies
governor's wife so the the the governor
of the colony was amanda william phipps
the girls accused his wife and the
magistrates in court said
you're wrong you've made a mistake move
on
right that suggests to me they didn't
believe it reverend hale one of the
reverends they accused his wife they
said nothing happened she wasn't
arrested either um
all sorts of examples
like this um they accused a
man called reverend samuel willard who
was um
at the time the acting president of
harvard it's a very powerful man very
god-fearing godly man and they accused
him
and the magistrate said no
you must be thinking of constable john
willard who has the same surname but
he's already you've already accused him
and he's in prison so we can move on now
so there's all these examples where we
can tell that the elites didn't really
believe it there was one moment in court
where a girl pulled out small
broken off bit of a knife a little bit
of a blade with some blood and said oh
this woman just sent her spirit out and
stabbed me with this and a man in the
court said that's from my knife it broke
off yesterday and you saw it and you
picked it up
and the court just said okay well we'll
ignore that and move on even though she
was just outed as a liar
so
why that's important for what we're
going through now is there are all these
crazy activists online without avatar
anime avatars and
they will scream all their nonsense they
see fascists everywhere everyone's a
fascist a homophobic nazis whatever they
see it everywhere and they probably
believe it and they're the equivalent of
the girls who are pointing the finger
and charging people but then you have
the politicians the civil servants the
journos the people who when you ask them
what is a woman they go ah um well
it's complicated and uh and you see the
fear in their eyes um
they know
that all of this is [ __ ] um but
they're gonna go along with it because
they think they will preserve themselves
by doing so that's what the elites in
salem did that's why it went on for as
long as it did it went on for a year
just every year
um so i think those comparisons are
really are really important because i
think the problem isn't the activists
the problem is capitulation to the
activists we you know we we see it again
and again they are so powerful now
among all of our major institutions the
civil service they're in the nhs the day
that vladimir putin invaded ukraine the
ministry of defense on that day put out
a tweet talking about how their lgbt
plus coffee morning had been such a
success and we got to talk about
pansexuality
you know which seems frivolous but it's
the ministry of defense
you know on the same day the daily mail
reported that mi6 and mi5 were urging
their spies to acknowledge their white
privilege now it wouldn't matter if it
was just activists it matters because
it's the powerful people last year in
ontario a school board
which is in charge of 30 schools removed
5 000 books from the school libraries
because they considered them to be
offensive and harmful because they
create contained outdated stereotypes of
ethnic groups they burned a number of
the books on a on a pyre and they used
the ashes to fertilize a tree a
beautiful gesture and they called this a
flame purification ceremony now this is
a straight out of the nazi play but you
can't i mean you can't
the burning of books you're thinking of
the open plots in in berlin you're
thinking you know it you can't evade
that and you're certainly calling it
something as orwellian as a flame
purification ceremony that wouldn't
matter if it was a bunch of idiot
activist burning harry potter books as
they sometimes do and posting it on
instagram as they sometimes do this
matters because it is a school board a
district
people in authority
and they
although they may not be caught up in
the hysteria they know that they should
go along with it for their own good the
um arthur miller when he wrote the
crucible which is his dramatization of
the witch trials in salem it was written
in the early 50s i think 1952 1953
uh he wrote that because of mccarthyism
and he was so stimulated not
mostly he said he said this in an
interview with the new yorker he said
that mostly he was in he was he was
upset about
the people in power who were going along
with lies for self
you know for self preservation so it's
something that happens again and again
and uh so i i've tried in my book to
draw
this comparison with salem because like
i say i think
i think it reveals something about what
we're experiencing now
uh and i also think it reveals how we
might escape from it but maybe we'll
talk about that later on i don't know
i've been blathering on for a while now
what is it
i i i understand the dynamic i can see
the the parallels between the two
why do the elites the people who have
the power decide to comply
with a
group of people
that don't have any power was it was it
important in salem the fact that the two
girls were the niece and the daughter of
somebody that wasn't super low prestige
for instance had it have been the lowest
of the low would they have been given
the same
degree of uh room to speak
possibly we don't know that i mean
possibly it was considered particularly
horrifying that this was happening in a
reverend's house in the clergyman's
house
but
uh the girls were relatively powerless
but this was the thing is that that
and
the girls suddenly became powerful
through victimhood all of a sudden then
this is another major parallel i think
all of a sudden
these girls had found a way to be the
most powerful people in the community
they could sentence you to death
they could have you killed
and
and they were
but they were also able to say they were
on the side of the angels
right who does that remind you of
you know the the incredible power that
the social justice ideologues have
uh the power to destroy someone's life
and career if they just choose to do so
if they deliberately misinterpret or
misrepresent what someone says
uh and they can do it by saying that
they're the good guys they're the
virtuous hashtag love wins guys you know
that's that's them
so i um
whether it would have happened if it
were different girls whether it would
have started there were a lot of sort of
specific reasons why
it happened early on why it started the
way it did but once it had exploded they
could have been anyone really
but you know
the downside to that of course is and
the other the other parallel is
they the girls were powerful
but no one wanted to be around them they
were also
people were scared of them and after all
this ended
they
a lot of them had very great difficulty
in maintaining any kind of relationships
of any kind marriages or friendships
uh so and you notice that with the
extreme social justice activities if
you're in that group
you're safe
but
these aren't people you would want to be
friends with they turn on each other so
viciously sometimes as well they're
scary people and when all of this ends i
i can't imagine
uh this working out well
for them particularly but it's that it's
that dynamic of people using victimhood
as a means to bludgeon others and i
think that's where the the parallel is
absolutely clear
if you start to use weakness or
victimhood
as a as something to be upheld as
something to be pedestalized that seems
like a very dangerous position to get
yourself into because there is no limit
there is a limit to how competent you
can be your competence is limited by
your competence right but your ability
to pretend that you are a victim
is basically limitless the the whole
continues to go down as much as you want
but particularly if it's just based on
lived experience precisely what you feel
i mean i could say that anything has
traumatized me and therefore that's my
lived experience and therefore i can
decide
that
this the innocuous thing that you said
to me the other day was a homophobic
hate crime i've decided it was
homophobic and that by the way
is is is current police practice so
a precise part of this are a really
important part of this is the spectral
evidence thing it's the fact that
interpretation
and
a low barrier
for what constitutes verifiable
usable evidence
that facilitates all of this because
without without that you actually end up
crashing up against rigor and
screw reality yes
exactly right and that's going to be the
way out at the moment we have a police
force
that records hate crime on the basis of
the perception of the victim alone in
other words if someone decides that what
someone something that someone else did
was homophobic it's recorded as a hate
crime even if that person didn't mean it
that way it doesn't matter it's the
lived experience alone the police say it
explicitly on the college of policing
website perception of the victim by the
way they call them the victim rather
than complainant because of course it's
about lived experience so we don't need
a trial we can bypass due process um
similarly with spectral evidence same
thing but
the great thing about salem
and what eventually happened is uh the
deputy governor wrote to and he should
have done this straight away i don't
know why didn't he wrote to the leading
clergymen in the country and said oh by
the way is spectral evidence admissible
in court and they all replied and said
no
by no means it's not it's not admissible
it's not you can't use it to prosecute
and all of the cases collapsed so all
those dead people that they were they
were prosecuted for nothing and
and that was it done overnight done and
if
the police and the authority figures of
today
and the guardian and all the others that
uphold this nonsense if they were to say
look you've come to me with your lived
experience but your lived experience is
not evidence of anything beyond your own
experience and it cannot be extrapolated
to be used as such i can't say
based on my own experience of being gay
the times that i've been uh you know
homophobically abused or whatever and i
can't then say oh that means we live in
a deeply homophobic country no it means
i've experienced homophobia a few times
is it like so
that my lived experience
isn't invalid it you know and i'm not
it's not to suggest that you can't learn
from other people's personal experiences
i'm not saying any of that
but it can't be used as the basis to
formulate national policy
uh and so that's where i think the fact
that salem fell apart because of the
spectral evidence was deemed
inadmissible what if we all just decided
tomorrow lived experience we can't we
can't do anything with that we can't
draw anything from that
then
this stuff ends doesn't it
do you believe on balance that if you
were to get rid of lived experience
that it would be a net positive there
will be some people out there for whom
the law
or the way that uh
pains and issues are recognized doesn't
fit within existing paradigms of
justifiable things and they you know
there will be some people out there who
do have a lived experience that doesn't
have a pr precedent for them and they go
well look like i'm now no longer
protected people are no longer standing
up for me is that a bad thing
well like i say i'm not suggesting that
we shouldn't listen to people's
experiences and we shouldn't take them
seriously
uh you know what i am suggesting is that
they shouldn't be used to damn and
condemn
others because it's insufficient
i i think that's a i think that's a
fairly fair
uh way of looking at it i think you know
anecdotal evidence we all all know
is can be useful and illuminating but it
can't be anything that we base broad
conclusions on
and i think that's uh i don't think
that's a controversial thing to say
personally one of the other elements
here is that
it seems like the salem witch trials
were uh based around a legislative
process right this was happening in
court and everything hinged around the
lived experience stuff what you have now
it seems to me that the situation in the
modern world is a little bit more
complex because a lot of the enforcement
isn't necessarily coming from the powers
that be a lot of this enforcement is
coming along the sides and it's you know
bottom up right it's emergent not uh
dictated
how do you how are you going to deal
with that well it's a bit of both though
isn't it because those at the top are as
i say capitulating to these pressures
from below and laws are changing and and
things are you know
because it's capturing so many
institutions it's captured a number of
we've had a number of
near miscarriages of justice as a result
of this
because this stuff has seeped into the
legal system as well
thankfully it would appear at the moment
that the high courts are not captured so
what tends to happen is you'll get a
terrible decision in the court and it'll
be reversed on appeal by the higher
courts uh so this this is
one of the ways in which people like
mara fastata
eventually won her case what was that
maya fostata was a tax expert is a tax
expert sorry who who was uh dismissed
from her job because she uh she um
how can i say well she acknowledged the
biological reality of sex differences
because she has gender critical views
um and as a result of that she was a she
lost her job or her contract wasn't
renewed
and she took them to tribunal because
she said well look this is just because
of my personal beliefs uh they made up
all sorts of lies they claimed she'd
misgendered someone at work or harassed
someone and none of that was true and
that's all now on record but so she took
them to the tribunal but the tribe it
found in the employer's favor the
tribunal found in the employer's favor
and said that her opinions about
biological sex differences were not
worthy of respect in a civilized society
and i can't remember the exact phrase
it's a legal phrase but it's it's
something of that kind
so then she had to appeal and on the
appeal
it was and it was a it's a great thing
that marvel started won that appeal
because what that means is
there is now a precedent in law it is
now established in law
that to believe that there are two sexes
and that sex is immutable that is now a
protected belief by law
so now whenever any feminist gets fired
for making that statement uh the
employer has broken the law and it will
be reversed so what i'm saying is
we we can still rely on the courts to
resolve a lot of this at the moment but
what
if we don't stem this momentum and when
the high courts get captured
then we're screwed because then you're
in a situation like
you know some of these medical journals
that are now completely ideologically
captured where you get a major medical
journal massively reputable
magazine talking about how sex is a
spectrum
and you know and they know it's not
and i know it's not and i barely scrape
my biology gcse and i know it's not um
but you've got the top minds in the
world in this field
saying something that even i know is not
true so
that's really scary so yeah then you get
that legitimation crisis where figures
in authority can no longer be trusted at
the moment
we can't fully trust the police we can't
fully trust the
uh the the journalists so we can't fully
trust the politicians but the high
courts seem to be pretty sound at the
moment social media platforms as well i
suppose are a huge contributor here what
about um
i i read a post from andrew sullivan a
little while ago earlier on this year
where he thinks that we've passed peak
woke because he said he said that pequok
was june july 2020 and
i i don't really know i don't understand
the
burblings but i'm gonna try and bring
him on to have a discussion about this
but i don't really understand the
burblings below the surface but it
definitely does seem to me at least a
little bit like
the very extreme held social justice e
sort of views
are kind of becoming a meme of
themselves now
but i don't know if that's just my echo
chamber well i thought that before i
thought they were always a bit
ridiculous um
uh and i thought that we would just you
know laugh them off because so many of
them are really stupid you know when you
get
i know like like the the william hogarth
exhibition in london recently where the
curators had put up all these really
weird
notices next to all the pictures
problematizing them and talking about
slavery and things that weren't
necessarily relevant to the
the pictures and so there was one even
there was a
self-portrait of william hogarth sitting
on a chair
and the note said the chair's made of
wood and that wood probably came from
some plantation
so
you know maybe we should it was really
really weird so that stuff's quite funny
or when like when they put trigger
warnings on major works of literature
and in universities like um
the old man in the sea the hemingway
book which had a trigger warning that
said warned about that this book
contains scenes of graphic fishing
you know and so stuff like that
it's funny
and and
but it's still being that was applied by
a major university by academics in a
major university we're not talking about
these
mad pink-haired activists we're talking
about
people and figures of authority i would
like to think i i mean andrew sullivan
i'm a big admirer of and i hope i hope
he's right prescient yeah that would be
nice if he was the cassandra yeah i
don't know i mean
part of me thinks
i can't work out whether it's an
intellectual ghetto to throw these
people into higher academia where they
basically get
at least they're not looking after
sending rockets to mars and stuff but
then when you tell me that on the day
that russia invades ukraine that mi6 is
concerned about their
equity coffee morning or whatever it was
that they did yeah that makes me feel
like maybe maybe this has started to
creep into it so maybe we're not past
pequok maybe it is
continuing know all of this started
obviously in the humanities uh
um
but now it is actually seeping into
the sciences so you know when we say
it's
the problem is the next step of this is
going to be i think i mean i don't know
i'm not profit i i think the next step
of this is going to be
how do we now read the sciences are we
already had people like what's her name
uh professor
gutierrez
talking about how mathematics itself
operates as whiteness
and and and we've had academics
problematizing the notion that two plus
two equals four
which almost feels like they're trolling
us like they're they've picked up 1984
and they're going to troll us with that
but they they mean it
um but there's a really good example
which i mentioned in the book which is
in new zealand where um
the government in new zealand has tried
to incorporate maori
origin stories into the science
curriculum of schools because they these
are alternative ways of knowing and this
is a belief system
that thinks that the the human race was
created by the god of the forest and
that rain drops are the tears of another
goddess
and that is now being taught next to
you know osmosis and peristalsis and
whatever whatever like whatever
photosynthesis like
oh and by the way when it rains that's a
goddess crying maybe
maybe because it's alternative ways of
and what was worse about that is that a
professor of the royal society of new
zealand actually uh signed a letter was
one of these people that signed a letter
saying you know whilst it's great to
respect indigenous cultures and by you
know really really implicating that and
not being at all uh belligerent they
just said look it's not science is about
the discovery of empirical truths
and so therefore we it's not appropriate
to bring these kind of belief systems in
in
uh and then he got absolutely nailed and
attacked and all of the signatories of
that letter were denounced by
the vice chancellor of the university by
um the royal society uh by all of these
major figures um
and then and they've been told they were
told they'd caused hurt and harm and
that was the thing uh so
if scientists
are being attacked and punished
for defending science if leading science
journals and magazines
are
you know publishing things that they
know not to be true because it satisfies
an ideological uh perspective
uh
then
that's actually gonna have a major
knock-on effect because it's not like
it's all very well in an english
department
if i if i think that shakespeare's
sonnets
are a problematic um you know
hetero-patriarchal cis-normative
text
uh that would be better off without well
who cares right because
it's it's the sonnets and uh you know
that's
we know i wouldn't want to live without
the sonnets but
we could
but could we live without
medicine
could be
sanitation um
i think when it comes to the sciences
things either work or they don't
you know
i i just
i think that might be the next
battleground that maybe some people
aren't quite seeing we're seeing it
creeping in wasn't there a tweet today
actually
uh where someone i think it was the
scientific american
is that right is that magazine yeah
scientific america i think they tweeted
out a thing about
the myth of
binary sex
like
that this really unscientific thing that
human beings before the 18th century
thought understood human sex as being
there's only one sex now we believe
there's two sexes but actually it's all
wrong there's many many many multiple
sexes which there aren't and no
no expert believes that i saw i saw in
the economist the other day
gay people are reclaiming an islamic
heritage in the old days muslims were
quite tolerant of homosexuality history
is complicated and prejudice has ancient
roots nonetheless activists can point to
periods of the islamic past where arab
rulers were more liberal about sex they
relate to how caliph amin in the 9th
century baghdad had a male lover and
defeated gay poets
that's that's true i mean there were
there were moments in islamic history
when homosexuality was more tolerated
that that's not a lie
um
but to suggest that gay muslims don't
have it hard these days
which i imagine is the implication there
right yeah yeah i mean
[ __ ] me like
that's not helpful to gay muslim people
right that kind of
so you can reclaim it i mean anyone that
decides to reclaim their
gay muslim heritage in modern day
baghdad i fear would if they took the
advice of the economist would be coming
up again but i think that shows as well
just how narrowly bound these
discussions are like it is very much
for all the talk of the bourgeois
white cis heteronormative people sat in
the ivory tower talk like it that's you
those are the people that are
proselytizing about this this is
literally like how
blinkered can your worldview be for you
to not realize that there is genuine
harm out there and this is you know
it does feel a little bit like banging
my head against a wall talking about
this stuff because you're like look
there are genuine problems that are
occurring many of them are occurring to
people that are in minorities or groups
that are genuinely oppressed and the
more that you take
up people's
reserve tank of [ __ ]
to be spent on something which does not
justify spending it on yeah that means
that they do not it's the boy that cried
wolf all over again
yeah oh absolutely what was that quote
from uh
i quoted it in another book i wrote um
from muslim girl magazine i think was
talking about the prophet muhammad was
an intersectional feminist
was an actual i didn't make that up um
you know you have to yeah yeah exactly i
mean it goes back to this point we have
to acknowledge reality as it is and we
have to
stop i mean this intersectional stuff
because we end up pitting the most
reactionary elements within islam at the
very top of this pile it's so weird to
me
did you see me and douglas spoke about
this did you see that uh white gay
privilege is now a thing
oh yeah of course yeah
yeah i mean i know the gays are not
oppressed anymore yeah you are basically
straight now because of your skin color
you're a honorary straight again
basically yeah so uh
helen lewis just released a bbc
four
podcast called the church of social
justice what's your view on whether or
not
social critical social justice is a
religion because people often sort of
bandy this about is that true well
that's my whole book isn't it
but like how just how
similar do you do you draw the the
perils in terms of religion you know
like the the um
sacred texts the idols exactly i mean
there's like look it's a way that you
can understand it if you if you perceive
it as a religion because look it's it's
a it's a belief system albeit of a
secular kind
which which is largely faith-based so
they believe in these invisible power
structures uh they believed in lived
experience they believed in all this
stuff that you have to just take on
trust and the people who are uniquely
qualified to detect these power
structures those who have studied
whiteness studies or whatever whatever
it might be
um so there's that element to it but
also it it bears all the hallmarks of of
fundamentalist religion insofar as it uh
will not tolerate any dissent it attacks
heretics it roots them out
it uh it excommunicates anyone who
strays from it it has its own litter
liturgical can't doesn't it
phrases that you are expected to repeat
like trans women are women trans men are
men etc uh it has its own esoteric
language religious pseudo-religious
language
uh it it has its own gods
uh judith butler kimberly crenshaw
michelle foucault its own saints at
least uh it has its foundational holy
texts uh
it has all sorts of things in common
uh with religion um
so yeah i think it's a really helpful
way to understand it but also the main
thing i think
is that as stephen weinberg the the
physicist said
uh
you know without religion you have good
people doing good things and bad people
doing bad things
for good people to do bad things that
takes religion
and it makes sense of things for us
because
the inquisitors
who who burned people at the stake
strapped people to the rack thought they
were doing god's work thought they were
the good guys
the uh social justice activists who have
this incredible unmitigated rage and
ferocity who will happily destroy your
life they will end you they are
merciless
and and and brutal
but they think they're doing
good
and and that i think is the
that's why it makes sense to think of it
as a religion
that's that's why
it it it helps us to comprehend why
look a lot of the people in this
movement will be bullies and will be the
sadists it attracts people of that kind
because they get to do what they want to
do and look like the good guys and they
get away with it
but most of them will be really decent
people who think that they are upholding
social justice and who will think that
they are combating racism combating
fascists they probably believe that
fascists are everywhere even though all
the studies tell us that they're not
so
that's why i think the comparison with
religion is important to understand
because i don't want to just dismiss
these people as all
you know if you just judge them on their
actions you think god these people are
psychotic they have no human empathy
just none
but it can't be that can it because i
have a fundamental belief in humanity
and i think some people some people are
sociopaths some people have no empathy
and some of them will be part of the
social justice movement sure
but i think most of them are pretty good
people who just they've just got it very
wrong
yeah so there has to be uh an
explaining principle if you have a faith
in
human nature
you've got a quote from c.s lewis that
says of all tyrannies a tyranny
sincerely exercised for the good of its
victims may be the most oppressive seems
like that relates to what you were just
talking about yeah yes exactly because
i think as he goes on to say because
you've got the your own conscience is on
your is on your side you know
yeah i think that's i think that's right
the the
it's it's worse it's more brutal because
because they think well it's partly
because
they think any dissenters are
you know anyone who disagrees with them
has the slightest
point of political disagreement is not
just wrong or naive
or ill-informed but evil yeah right
yeah and so therefore they monster you
and you know
the you know
i get a lot of people objecting to the
things i believe
99 of them don't ever
faithfully reflect what i believe it's
always things they've assumed i believe
it's always things that the monster
version of me that they've created
believes
um there is a parallel universe with a
monster andrew doyle who is a fascist
evil wants all gay people to die
etcetera all the stuff i'm accused of
believing but i don't believe any of
that and not only that it's on record
everything i think is really really out
there so a little
basic research would disabuse them of
their
of their uh views
uh jk rowling is another example the
idea that the idea that jk rowling
someone who is so sort of left-wing and
empathetic and gives so much of her
money away to good causes uh
is now routinely smeared as far right
fascist
evil witch
uh you know even in the mainstream
commentary she's called hateful and
transphobic
and she's never ever said anything
publicly that is hateful or transphobic
so you're dealing with a complete
fantasy world and
and that's why i wanted to write the
book i want to try and make sense of how
have we reached this point where
people like me who just
hold liberal values and free speech and
equality and are opposed to racism and
discrimination
even that if someone like me can be
monstered as far right and nazi that's
why i opened my book with
the uh the story of my friend who
started screaming at me that i'm a nazi
because
i can't make sense of that what is that
world what that's a world in which
reason
and logic and rationality is just it's
gone it can't that it's it's not there
it's a fantasy world now and i think we
need to
get back to reality let's ditch let's
jettison this fantasy perspective most
disputes that i see online or even in
the mainstream media
are
figments of of someone's imagination
they are two people arguing against
specters that they've conjured
they're not really listening and they're
not really talking about the issues and
i think it's really sad actually
you mentioned there about jk rowling
being
accused of being far right and i'm sure
you get you get the same accusations as
well is it even correct do you think to
characterize the culture war is left
versus right at the moment 100 wrong
i mean
it's um
one of the reasons it's wrong i mean if
you take the uk
uh the labour party which is the
traditionally left-wing party although
not very left-wing now uh
is completely um immersed in this
ideological movement and and buys into a
lot of it the tory party however the the
conservatives
have presided over most of the problems
over the past 12 years they've let it
through they've let it happen
they are also woke
they have a the new online safety bill
which uses all of the language of social
justice about how words can cause harm
uh
they are part of the problem
their proposals to revise the gender
recognition act same thing they believe
in gender identity ideology or at least
they will pay lip service to it
um we're starting to see pushback now
with because they can see how it hasn't
gone down well with the voters so now
you see those the two people who are
running for the tory leadership both
coming out and saying no uh there's a
difference between men and women right
they're they're they're they're
realizing what's happening now but
this is not a right left issue and even
if it were you can vote in a tory
government a labor government you can't
vote out the civil service you can't
vote out the quangos all of which are
completely captured by this ideology
uh
whoever is in government you will have
woke policies running the police running
the nhs
and it's really serious you know when
when
uh the nhs have a policy called annex b
which means that uh they house people on
the basis they accommodate people they
have single sex wars right but people
are accommodated according to their own
gender identity not according to
biological sex and what that means is if
i were to say i'm a woman they would
have to put me on a ward with women
and if one of the female patients
complained about my presence the
official written policy of the nhs is
that
staff nurses and doctors would have to
say no you are mistaken there are no men
on this ward
in other words it is written into
official nhs policy that they have to
gaslight their patients should they
raise an objection to this when there
was a sexual assault there was a rape on
a ward and when the police turned up
and said there's been a rape on this
ward or if there's been an allegation of
a rape the staff at the hospital said
that cannot have happened because there
are no men on this ward knowing full
well there was someone with male
genitalia on that ward now so that
it matters that sort of stuff obviously
because there's a rape victim all of a
sudden who isn't going to get justice
because some
people have decided that this is
progressive somehow
there was a story that i saw that came
up yesterday trans prisoner convicted of
who was convicted of manslaughter
impregnated two inmates and then
attempted to remove his testicles with a
razor a new jersey inmate landed himself
in hospital after he tried to remove his
testicles with a razor demi miner who
identifies as transgender engaged in
self-harm after he was transferred to a
men's prison because he had been
impregnated to two inmates while in a
woman's facility according to his blog
justice for demi miner felt hopeless
because prison officials doubted that he
is transgender i showed my medical
records showing that i've been on
hormones for years and awaiting gender
affirming surgery which they're delaying
started cutting again with a razor i
began making an incision to remove my
testicle in my head i just wanted the
pain to stop i just wanted to to get out
of this they don't know what the hell
i'm going through more than a decade ago
minor unleashed his a hell of his own
back in 2011 he tried to rob his former
foster parents approximately nine months
after he left their charge and then he
stabbed someone to death who was 69
years old however one of the at least
one of the two women that he impregnated
is keeping the baby so um the baby is
going to have two parents soon
i mean that's obviously someone who is
very disturbed and that's obviously
someone who needs help right but it's
also a rapist who shouldn't be
in a woman's facility
right clearly and that and that so
female prisoners are some of the most
vulnerable people i mean they may have
committed crime but a lot of them have
i've read some statistic about the the
number of them that have had blunt force
head trauma because so many of them have
been victims of domestic abuse and it's
it's very high there's a lot of a lot of
troubled people there you don't want to
put an intact male
who is who has been convicted of sexual
assault what that's insane
i mean i think the reason why that was
that's still happening is because i
think people don't believe that's
happening i don't think people believe
it sounds ludicrous it sounds too
imp impossible
but but everyone's complicit the media
is complicit there was an article on the
bbc recently about a man i think it was
in new york
and it said um so this elderly woman
70s late 70s something like that this
elderly woman cut up two of her elderly
female friends and put them their heads
into bags and she'd already killed a few
of her and you and you're reading this
and you're thinking
it doesn't sound like an elderly woman
and you get to the bottom of the article
and it's almost like an aside
of this person uh ident transitioned
recently it's like
that's it's a man
it's a male
serial killer and and that's not
journalism if you're if you're lying to
us for most of the article
and then a footnote and then a basic
footnote so i mean it's
if you just skinned the article you
think that oh wow that's weird you know
there's suddenly elderly female serial
killers
um
i i i mean
but this is why we've got to push back
on it we've got to restore the primacy
of truth truth really does matter
and it has the stakes are high when
people are getting raped and attacked
that's that's really serious um
anyway sorry we've gone very serious now
but it's serious isn't it it is it is
serious stuff man yeah i mean this is
the thing
part of me
wants
the
part of me thinks that the the best way
to push back against this is to br it's
it's almost like a real life ad hominem
or sorry no it's not it's like a real
life uh reductio ad absurdum right it's
like look this is the most insane story
that you could think of and it actually
happens to have happened the white gay
privilege thing is a a real world
demonstration of what happens when you
have intersectionality right when you
have a hierarchy of grievance you end up
having people that are no longer like
this was something that was it was
almost prophetic some of the stuff that
was being talked about four or five
years ago if you have intersectionality
it means that people are going to start
to climb this ladder and there's one
person on the planet and they're the
most oppressed and that means that they
can talk down to everybody else and blah
blah blah
so part of me thinks constantly bringing
up these stories
is an important part of highlighting
look this is actually happening this is
something that everybody needs to be
conscious of and then the other part
thinks well does it give
malign actors uh an attention does it
co-opt certain people into the into this
movement do you understand what i mean
like part of it needs to be the warning
and part of it needs to be that oh [ __ ]
well what if this what if this makes the
problem worse
well i think the implications of
intersectionality have i mean
i think the original
idea behind it made sense
i mean
i don't know do you know about where it
came from and yeah yeah yeah yeah so
that made sense to me you know kimberly
crenshaw was talking about a specific
case where
black women were falling through the
cracks because they were
facing impression for being both black
and female
there are there's a legitimate point
there um
but it's become a kind of
a religious dogma
based on the idea of of hierarchies of
privilege and and it reduces people to
their demographic and it says that you
are more oppressed if you have these
qualities and less oppressed if you have
those qualities and it fails completely
to take into account any kind of
individual circumstances or who who
people are
and it often forgets about class and
money of course as well that's the other
thing so it is a it is a flawed way and
it has real life effects as well it has
very deleterious effects when for
instance
people talk about white privilege and
the discourse of white privilege well
there's now
a reason to believe and and and people
have
uh confirmed that it has muddled policy
thinking when it comes to white
working-class kids who are you know
among the lowest uh educationally in the
country at the moment
uh it actually has an effect on people
so it's a it hasn't worked it's a bad
idea
uh and i think we should move on from it
what was that racism of the gaps thing
that you were talking about
oh well uh it's the it's the um
the baseline of critical race theory
which is uh
this this notion that all
equality inequalities of outcome are
evidence of
racist practice so in other words uh
if you can't explain why there are
different different outcomes
you just say well that must be racism in
the way that
if you can't explain something that it's
the god of the gaps phenomenon it's the
equivalent of that if you can't it's
it's explain something in nature
then it's god
god fills that hole similarly with this
racism fills that hole but of course the
charge of racism is really serious and
and you have to be able to uh
prove it well it's kind of becoming less
serious now because of its
proliferation because of how many people
are being accused of being a racist i
know that's a real that's a real worry
isn't it
the fact that when i'm online and i hear
someone called a racist
i just assume that's probably not true
yeah it's probably you know jk rowling
is called a racist sometimes it's called
a nazi something you just think
the word does you know when when it's
used that promiscuously then then yeah
it becomes denuded of all meaning so uh
and it should never be the case should
it that my default assumption is that
that word doesn't isn't has been
inaccurately applied
that's terrible it definitely doesn't
help the
movement it definitely doesn't help it
doesn't help us to communicate like it's
it's just a very messy way to
communicate so i had this guy on the
show a guy called gwyndobogle and uh he
has this concept where he says when
intelligent people affiliate themselves
to ideology their intellect ceases to
guard them against wishful thinking and
instead begins to fortify it causing
them to inadvertently mastermind their
own delusion and to very cleverly become
stupid and this is i think
why i mean it's [ __ ] brilliant but
it's what
i had a question for you which is why is
it that this seems to be
disproportionately held these viewpoints
seem to disproportionately be held by
intelligent people why is it that their
rationality hasn't been able to guard
them against something which seems to be
playing around up against reality it's
swimming upstream
such an important question i wish i knew
the answer to that um you're absolutely
right though it does seem to be that
intelligent people are particularly
susceptible to this i mean the fact that
academics are now mostly activists right
and the fact that they they they bought
into this stuff uh yeah intelligence is
no prophylactic against this
this belief system you know there have
always been intelligent
ideologues of all of all stripes um
so why is that the case
i guess because however intelligent we
are
ideologies will be appealing to us
because thinking is hard
even if you are really smart perhaps
possibly especially if you are really
smart and you know maybe
an ideology solves everything for you it
says you know this is this is the way
the world works i mean you don't have to
you don't have to do your thinking for
yourself anymore and i i think that's as
true as in of intellectuals as anything
else it's less about how intelligent you
are and more about how your capacity for
critical thinking and i don't i think
everyone is capable of critical thought
um i wonder whether i wonder whether
people like the idea of a pre-determined
framework of thinking
if you are the type of person that has
vacillations about your view of the
world more than the average person
because it actually it nets you a bigger
positive if you're not somebody that is
hugely inquisitive or curious or
introspective and doesn't hold all of
these different viewpoints in your mind
at one time there is less of a benefit
to outsourcing your thinking to somebody
else because there isn't as much
thinking going on in any case i wonder
whether it's almost like a relief to
people that have a lot of big questions
and can't find answers to them to just
go for something that is kind
it's just an answer i don't care if it's
the right answer it just is a answer
well i think i think the social justice
activists depend upon that don't they
because they are offering answers to
complicated difficult ideas and they're
often very simple appealing sound bite
style answers to these things uh and
they and they they've already sort of
problematized things because they keep
redefining words and they keep telling
you
you don't understand this and they keep
throwing jargon at people and saying you
you won't understand it because you
haven't studied critical race theory so
just let us do the thinking for you
we'll come in and we'll tell you what's
problematic and what's not and what you
should say and what you shouldn't say
going back to what you said about
religion i learned is it was it thomas
blackwell was he the first guy to
translate the
bible into english and before that time
well uh
who's the first
who
oh i shouldn't have had that glass of
wine i know it's william tyndale
it's william tyndall well if this if
google tells me oh this it's debated the
first person to complete the english
language version of the bible dates from
1382 was credited to john wycliffe
tyndale's bible is credited with being
the first bible in the english language
to work directly from hebrew and greek
yeah maybe it's
tyndale bible is on uh wikipedia and we
know how accurate that is so we'll we'll
give you that but
my point being that
previous to that the only way that the
regular person would have access to the
sacred text were through
vicariously through
the priests right it was like look you
pure plebeians
you come to me
i will tell you what god says not only
am i the person that can
convene with the divine and that is
proselytizing about it but i'm actually
the only person that fully understands
literally fully understands because you
actually can't read the language which
would have been latin i'm going to guess
at the time
you can't read what this is oh that's
why they that's why they resisted
translating the bible into into the
vernacular absolutely
because it allows people to see the
scriptures for themselves and and begin
to interpret for themselves yeah
absolutely i i think that's really
similar to what's going on now i mean
look at the way that some of these
ideologues write
look at the way that judith butler
writes with this terrible turged
garrulous prose that is almost it looks
like it's engineered to to to uh to
confuse people
you know these ideas that she's
expressing should be able to be
expressed with elegance and clarity and
if you can't do so uh then you're
failing and i get that sometimes
difficult concepts require difficult
language i'm not dismissing that but try
reading her stuff it's it's
you know it's not
it's bad writing
is what it is
so i think
but it's but there's a there's a point
to it if you can if you throw all this
jargon down people do get intimidated
look at look at whenever these academic
activists get in like people like um i
won't name names actually what's the
point um when when they start getting to
rouse on twitter and they start throwing
down firstly they sometimes throw down
their qualifications they're like i've
got a phd in this and they do all as a
any sentence that begins with as a as an
expert in the yeah and then they throw
down this jargon and they are counting
on that deterring people
the reason why in my book i go through
critical race theory and what are the
key tenets of critical race theory in
clear ways because i don't think it's
very complicated and i think anyone can
understand it and i think
but they are counting on people not
understanding it and they gaslight all
the time they say
they say things like oh yeah you're
talking about critical race theory
that's totally about law it's a legal
discipline yeah that was its origins
it originated from legal scholars
um like derrick bell and and
and and delgado and it starts with
it starts with
law and then it gets rolled out into
education and all areas of public life
and and so when you talk about critical
race theory in schools and you often get
i see it all the time online people say
you're talking about critical race
theory in education it's not in
education it's a legal thing
and you're like there are literally
there are
hundreds of articles about critical race
theory and education there are books
called critical race theory in education
so it's it's just
they
they just don't want like you say the
plebeians
to to have a seat at the table so it's
kind of it's kind of a little bit like
saying
that hammer that i just hit you over the
head with that's not a weapon that's a
diy device right exactly
it's it's really paternalistic isn't it
it is so elitist that's why that's what
really wants very wanky very very wanky
but it's establishment as well like so
it's it's it's basically
it's the elite i mean i consider the
woke to be like the
the clergy of our age basically
and they are the the elite they are the
high priests who are saying
you don't understand and you can never
understand so just trust me
you know
and
i
anyway i finished
i don't know what more to say but i'm
starting to get slightly grumpy about it
so i'll i'll uh
enjoy the rest of your wine that's what
you need to do bit more wine more wine
or less wine i don't know i think i
think it's because i've had a long day
and normally i'm very calm and sort of
measured when i talk about this stuff
but i've had a long day and half a glass
of wine i'm like i'm just sick of it
like
do you find yourself here here's an
interesting question do you find
yourself able to
emotionally detach from the fact that
you are now
swimming permanently in the waters of
this sort of stuff you know for me
because the show has a lot of latitude i
can talk to some astrophysicists or i
can do or whatever right like i can exit
out of the culture walls whenever i want
and and i can temper that accelerator
whereas for you this this is a lot more
uh a broader amount of the time that you
spend working is that difficult for you
yes sometimes it i feel like i'd rather
do anything but
um
i do feel a kind of obligation though
because i care about this stuff i care
about liberal values i care about the
this retreat this societal retreat this
regression and i do want to at least
to be able to say that i tried to do
something about it
um but i do uh
on my show for instance i will often
invite people who aren't talking about
these issues talking about other things
because i i do want to broaden those
sort of things sometimes i will write an
article or a piece
about something that's got nothing to do
with it i've got um
a chat i've written a chapter for a book
that's coming out next month which is
about the poet walter de
and so stuff like that i can just do
something else and does that feel
relieving when you you get to step out
yeah it's great you know i just had a
musical on him in belfast which was
which was nothing to do with the culture
war and that's great i've just i've got
another musical in development at the
moment which is about
uh plastic surgery in world war ii
so you know
it's it's quite good to be able to step
out and
i like getting away from it i sort of
depend on it a lot of the stuff i read
is not not to do with the culture war as
well yeah well i think
one of the concerns that i would have
and it's thankful that you know my
friends like you and douglas and stuff
that do
uh jump feet first into these
discussions a lot of the time have other
things as well
yeah
you see
the
total
perverting nature of living and
breathing this stuff i actually think
that james lindsay is someone who
probably suffered with that a good bit
that he just went so head first into
this stuff and was kind of catapulted to
to the forefront the battlefront of a
lot of these discussions
that it it just con it seemed to totally
consume him and like
he has said hasn't he since he was
booted off twitter he said that
actually it feels like a big relief
i haven't seen that where did he put
that out
it was in a video i saw
i just caught a glimpse of that wouldn't
surprise me that wouldn't surprise me he
said that it feels like a reprieve or
something like it feels like
so i get it like i think you know i like
james a lot i think he's a really great
guy and i think getting away from
twitter may be a wonderful thing for him
you know could be i i would love to get
off twitter that's my goal right
eventually retire i'll be able to retire
from working no no no i want to be able
to retire from twitter well to be fair
the book that i'm working on next is
nothing to do with the culture also
there we go so there's you know i can do
other things exciting i'm looking
forward to speaking to you about that as
well let's bring this one home mate uh
if people want to keep up to date with
all of the stuff that you do where's
best to go
um i think uh either watch me on free
speech nation which is my show on gb
news which is every sunday at seven
o'clock
uh or if they want to come to twitter
i'm at andrew
doyleunderschool.com
uh and if they want to read my new book
it's called the new puritans and that is
kind of
my last word on the culture war base i
mean i've basically said everything i've
got to say about it i can't draw a line
underneath that with it within that book
so i think that would be the way to
if you're interested in what i think
about this stuff and and obviously i'm
very much aware that you know we're
having a chat now and
we're talking and and we're only getting
half the picture because there are
things i'm not thinking of that i should
think of and there are and perhaps i'm
not expressing myself as well as i as i
might but in the written word in a book
length thing you're able to really
concentrate and draw out and rewrite and
clarity is all there so
that's that's why i'd recommend that
people buy the book
andrew i appreciate you mate thank you
thanks a lot what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]